Buonasera a tutte a tutti quello che vi
propongo questa sera è un viaggio Ed un
incontro un viaggio anche storico lo
vedremo tra poco e un incontro con
particolari soggetti che in realtà sono
già state anticipate nell'introduzione
dunque la mia prima domanda Quella non
tra parentesi chi manca in realtà una
risposta molto facile
ma
Pingo di mantenere un po' la suspance e
parto descrivendomi in realtà le due
immagini alternative Quella di destra
probabilmente è conosciuta alla maggior
parte di voi si tratta di una
manifestazione di protesta contro la
violenza sulle donne che costituisce lo
sappiamo purtroppo tutti dalle pagine
quotidiane dei giornali dalle notizie un
fenomeno particolarmente allarmante
forse conoscete meno
la fotografia sinistra quel signore lì
si chiama ed Roberts si chiamava ed
Roberts era un attivista per i diritti
civili delle persone responsabilità
siamo Berkley in California Dunque e ed
e Roberts
stanno protestando per ottenere
l'accessibilità
dell'università e del campus annesso
quindi rivendicano sostanzialmente
l'effettività del diritto allo studio
ritorno alla mia domanda iniziale chi
manca in un caso vediamo degli uomini
con disabilità nell'altro vediamo delle
donne senza disabilità
incrociamo i dati mancano le donne con
disabilità In realtà quindi auto
denuncio subito perché se noi
ampliassimo la fotografia dove vedete
the Roberts vedremo anche delle donne
con disabilità ma il fatto che
partecipassero fin da subito alla
rivendicazione dei diritti civili non
significa che a queste donne fosse stato
dato veramente voce e dunque che fossero
realmente visibili quello che mi
interessa capire è capire con voi è
perché mancano le donne con disabilità e
la ragione è data da una parola con la
quale Oggi siamo abbastanza
in confidenza potremmo dire
intersezionalità Sono convintissima che
almeno alcuni di voi sappiano che questa
parola esiste poi capiamo bene
esattamente che cosa sia questo è un
altro discorso ma per capirlo è una
parola che è stata coniata Alla fine
degli anni 90 del XX secolo da una
giurista statunitense che si chiama
Kimberly The Clash e che ha parlato
delle donne afroamericane
è una pensatrice visuale quindi ci
propone di immaginare
e immaginiamo in particolare un incrocio
stradale dove abbiamo degli assi della
discriminazione che si intersecano
Creation fa il discorso sulle donne
afroamericane noi lo facciamo sulle
donne con disabilità ma il risultato non
cambia lungo un asse della
discriminazione abbiamo il sessismo
lungo l'altro asse della discriminazione
abbiamo labilismo
sul sessismo non mi soffermo perché
tendenzialmente lo conosciamo labilismo
consiste nella proiezione di un
particolare tipo di soggetto di corpo
come tipicamente umano
il che porta a rilegare tutto ciò che
non si conforma alla norma nella sfera
del non umano o comunque a creare delle
gerarchie tre soggetti e in particolare
l'idea di corpo e di soggetto che c'è
stata tramandata della tradizione
filosofica occidentale
fa leva su un'idea di soggetto come
soggetto autonomo razionale e dove
l'autonomia è strettamente connessa o
diventa Indipendenza dunque la capacità
di fare tutto da sé di essere
autosufficienti autonomi non dipendere
da nessuno e un soggetto razionale
pensate a Cartesio Cogito ergo sum dove
il corpo non c'è
perché siamo ragione ora chiaramente
tutto questo porta ad escludere le
persone con disabilità o perché non sono
pienamente razionali o perché hanno un
corpo che è un corpo che si inceppa è
una macchina che non funziona
adeguatamente secondo i canoni che
culturalmente storicamente sono
considerati una normalità dunque
abilismo se si smobilismo e ritorno alle
metafora dell'incrocio si intersecano e
al centro di questa intersezione si
trova la donna con disabilità
discriminata in quanto donna e in quanto
persona con disabilità
che subisce l'impatto dei veicoli che
stanno percorrendo Questo incrocio ci
troviamo davanti un incidente
l'effetto della discriminazione non è
semplicemente la somma tra sessismo e
abilismo ma l'impatto è devastante
la discriminazione non si somma ci
direbbero le donne con disabilità ma si
moltiplica
E allora cosa porta Questa interazione
tra sessismo e abilismo ad una serie di
stereotipi
se gli uomini di norma sono pur ragione
e le donne sono associate alla
corporeità storicamente sono state
associate alla corporeità anche le donne
con disabilità subiscono il destino
delle donne Ma abbiamo detto è un
destino ancora peggiore perché in realtà
sono fortemente difettosi come tali
devianti rispetto alla normalità sono
soggetti dipendenti passivi dipendono da
prestatore più frequentemente della
prestatrice di cura
non sono capaci la presunzione di
incapacità femminile e storica pensate a
tutti i divieti anche giuridici che sono
stati dati alle donne imposte alle donne
proprio in ragione della loro presunta
incompetenza questi divieti storicamente
sono via Via Stati smantellati ne rimane
qualcuno A livello culturale Nel caso
però delle donne con disabilità
rimangono
le donne con disabilità sono considerate
eterne bambine e come tali è necessario
che qualcuno decida per loro è
necessario agire per il loro bene
E questo che ripercussioni ha sul
godimento dei diritti e sul
riconoscimento dei diritti questo
significa ad esempio che in una
procedura un procedimento di divorzio
difficilmente una donna con disabilità
venga affidato un figlio perché si
presume che non sia in grado di
prendersene cura questo giustifica il
fatto che ci siano una serie di norme
che legittimano altri soggetti a
decidere per loro come vi dicevo per il
loro bene
tutto questo si lega in realtà a
L'aspetto della sessualità in modo
particolarmente rilevante Per quanto
riguarda la violenza perché perché o si
presume che le donne con disabilità
siano soggetti asessuati che non abbiano
una vita sessuale Dunque banalmente
anche che non possano procreare
e quindi questo comporta ancora una
volta banalmente ma l'uso opposta per
provare a trasmettervi il messaggio che
non ci si pensa che questo comporta che
i centri ginecologici ad esempio non
siano accessibili non lo siano stati per
moltissimo tempo si sta iniziando ora a
cambiare le cose o questo comporta che
molti medici non sappiano l'interazione
tra la pillola anticoncezionale e
eventuali farmaci che una donna possa
dover prendere ragione della sua
disabilità non ci si pensa
oppure in alternativa alle donne con
disabilità sono soggetti ipersessuati
come tale da contenere sono
eccessivamente
dedite ad attività sessuale Qual è la
forma migliore per contenere una donna
con disabilità o un soggetto che
comunque appunto manifesti questa queste
tendenze eccessive contenerla e come si
contiene quella sterilizzazione non
consensuale quella che vedete a sinistra
è Cherry Bach il caso è un famoso caso
americano della del 1927 Cherry Bach era
una donna che il tempo si riteneva
avesse una forma di disabilità mentale
in realtà poi Si scoprirà che non era
così figlia di una donna con disabilità
dà alla luce una bambina Vivian a quel
punto si pone il problema di cosa fare
con questa donna che è incapace di
contenersi
e si decide di procedere alla
sterilizzazione che al tempo è legittima
nello Stato della Virginia C'è una legge
che lo consente in realtà non è l'unica
legge dal 1907 iniziano tutta una serie
di leggi che consentono la
sterilizzazione perché perché siamo
nell'epoca di Darwin di galton quindi
eugenetica
e il giudice Holmes che è incaricato di
decidere il caso o meglio di stabilire
se la legge della Virginia conforme alla
costituzione dice che non si pone alcun
problema di violazione dei diritti
perché Perché
è compito della nazione tenderà al
miglioramento della specie e dunque tre
generazioni di imbecilli Cito
testualmente sono sufficienti bisogna
prevenire chi è manifestamente anfit non
in grado di essere prestanti in qualche
modo dal propagare la propria specie
dunque
Tiriamo un sospiro di sollievo di
sollievo siamo in Europa siamo cent'anni
dopo
abbiamo una convenzione di Istanbul che
tutela le donne da ogni forma di
violenza e quindi anche le donne con
disabilità abbiamo una convenzione ONU
sui diritti delle persone con disabilità
Eppure
Eppure succede che se solo ci limitiamo
all'Europa Noi abbiamo solamente alcuni
stati che espressamente hanno delle
legislazioni che vietano la
sterilizzazione non consensuale delle
donne con disabilità tra questi e
l'Italia dove la sterilizzazione È
consentita per ragioni mediche Oltre a
questi ad esempio anche la Spagna la
legge spagnola è del dicembre 2020
una consapevolezza decisamente recente
la sterilizzazione non consensuale è una
forma di violenza di genere violenza che
specificamente colpisce non solo le
donne con disabilità ma ad esempio anche
le donne Rom le donne con disabilità
sono esposte alla violenza di genere
dunque non solo la sterilizzazione
in media almeno tre volte più delle
donne senza disabilità
e subiscono forme particolari di
violenza come ad esempio quella
psicologica è la forma di violenza più
utilizzata Ma la forma di violenza nei
confronti delle donne con disabilità
differisce da altresì caratterizza per i
particolari luoghi in cui viene compiuta
e per i soggetti parliamo anche delle
delle RSA o degli istituti parliamo
anche dei caregiver Dunque occultamento
invisibilità invisibilità dei soggetti e
invisibilità della violazione dei
diritti
potremmo dire quindi che allo stato
attuale nonostante
ci sia sicuramente una maggiore
sensibilizzazione in merito alla tutela
dei diritti delle donne con disabilità e
in merito al fatto che esistono queste
cose sono molto più vicino a noi di
quello che pensiamo anche perché molto
spesso Ad esempio una sterilizzazione
non consensuale viene nascosta dietro
l'appendicectomia
bene nonostante ci sia questa
consapevolezza vi dicevo ancora la
tutela dei diritti di queste donne può
essere considerato un'utopia
E allora
questo viaggio e questo incontro che vi
ho proposto nasce proprio con
dall'esigenza di riflettere e da un
incontro che io ho fatto dei temi prima
che delle persone Io questa sera sono
qui per parlarvi di questo tema
nella speranza di avere squarciato in
qualche modo un velo
perché sono convinta che molte molti di
voi in realtà non abbiano non sono mai
stati portati a riflettere su questi
temi mi basta anche un semplice non ci
avevo pensato Va benissimo così
esattamente questo
è squarciare un velo se la
l'invisibilità è una forma acuta di
discriminazione sociale prima ancora che
in termini giuridici che è il mio campo
bisogna agire su un piano culturale Io
vi dicevo non sono una donna con
disabilità secondo i canoni socio
culturali attualmente vigenti
non per questo il mio discorso è un
discorso sulle donne con disabilità ma
vuole essere un discorso con le donne
con disabilità perché se bisogna o
meglio se si vuole rendere possibile
un'utopia se quella della tutela dei
diritti e dei riconoscimento dei
soggetti e oggi parliamo di donne con
disabilità ma potremmo parlare di
tantissime altre soggetti ai margini
esclusi discriminati e oppressi
lo scatto culturale da fare è non
ritenere che certe battaglie e certe
questioni riguardino solamente alcuni E
in particolar modo in questo caso alcune
i diversi o le diverse
perché sono un problema di tutti e se
sono un problema di tutti quello che è
necessario fare è stringere alleanze
perché le loro battaglie sono anche le
mie battaglie si può partire da cose
molto piccole per squarciare questo velo
dell'invisibilità probabilmente avrete
notato che io ho messo in ogni slide la
descrizione immagine e non ho
giustificato il testo è una tecnica di
accessibilità
è una garanzia di un diritto è una cosa
semplicissima a cui banalmente non si
pensa
e
squarciare il velo porta a cambiare
atteggiamento culturale e a vedere una
serie di violazioni dei diritti a cui
prima Semplicemente non pensavamo se
iniziate a prestare attenzione a tutti
questi aspetti probabilmente vi potrete
accorgere che alcune cose che ci
sembrano naturali alcune violazioni di
diritti in particolar modo accade con la
disabilità che ci sembrano naturali
Anche perché si è sempre fatto così
in realtà naturali non sono
assolutamente e la prova potreste averla
sostituendo alla persona con disabilità
o alla donna con disabilità una persona
senza disabilità certe pratiche
risulterebbe ben accettabili prendete la
sterilizzazione in un consensuale se vi
dicessi è lecito o dovrebbe essere
lecito sterilizzare una donna mi
risponderesti Assolutamente no indignati
se la donna è con disabilità il discorso
si fa più complesso c'è da rifletterci
è un problema culturale
e dunque vi lascio con il movimento per
i diritti civili delle persone con
disabilità dove compaiono lo vedete
anche le donne Quindi mi sarei
sconfessato comunque anche alla fine del
mio intervento
dicendo che
l'utopia affinché sia possibile è un
qualcosa che riguarda In realtà noi e
tiene la nostra responsabilità a partire
appunto dal riconoscimento che
l'ingiustizia ovunque è una minaccia e
la giustizia dappertutto Grazie
[Applauso]